la députée LFI rachel kké a de nouve
faire parler d'elle oui déjà lors de son
élection euh bon ça avait suscité
l'attention des médias euh voilà alors
moi je je l'aimais bien en plus elle
ouais Mo auss on l'aime bien ou oui
voilà mais là on a un problème quand
même non même si on l'aime bien elle vit
toujours dans un HLM malgré son salaire
de député ou ou alors euh et Jean-Luc
Mélenchon lui il dit qu'il faut qu'elle
reste dans son H&M j'chon ton ami c'est
pas mon ami mais ton ami voy son pas mes
amis si si donc Rachel keké on va vous
faire un petit rappel de l'histoire
j'aimais bien savoir ce qu'on pense C
téléspectateurs donc cette député
comment elle elle touche en tant que
député alors elle touche exactement
9277 brut si on prend les trois
indemnitésou plus est dans un H&M de
fond plus 5373 d'avance de Freis manda
d'accord ok bon ben on va voir regardez
le le rappel de l'histoire j'ai hâte
d'avoir la vie de de Géraldine surtout
et moins celui de Gill Verde je suis
d'accord avec Gill je ah ouais alors
j'ai pas t av d'accord avec G ver dans
son cas elle précisément je trve qu'elle
ét irréprochable oui si c'est un cas
très particulier elle prévenu son
prévenuant
demand ancienne femme de ménage Rachel k
se fait connaître en 2019 lors d'une
intense Gree des techniciennes de
surface je me sens comment je peux dire
fier la tête haute j'aime ma dignité en
202 par insoumise Rachel kké devient
député qui a déjà touché 800 € 900 € par
mois personne vous savez pas ce que
c'est et mercredi dernier le média
factuel a fait une révélation la femme
habite toujours dans son HLM de 80 m²
malgré un revenu très confortable de
député de 7600 €. défendu par Jean-Luc
Mélenchon rachel kké a affirmé payer un
surloyer et compte bien rester dans son
logement elle ne compte pas faire
carrière en politique et ne sera pas élu
toute sa vie c'est pour cela qu'elle a
choisi de rester de vivre dans son
appartement
mais cette annonce surprend aujourd'hui
certains Français qui estiment qu'elle
devrait laisser sa place à d'autres
alors un an après son élection Rachel
keké vit dans un HLM malgré son salaire
de député êtes-vous
choqué alors êtes-vous choqué non non
non non non ah Pascal oui ah d'abord je
vais vous savez quoi je vais laisser la
parole à Gill verdz d'abordz c'est rare
je suis pas du tout choqué euh vous
voulez qu'elle vive où elle ne sera pas
éternellement députée elle habite là il
y a quatre enfants elle habite là depuis
des années c'est pas une professionnelle
de la politique elle paye un surloyer le
bailleur c'est parfaitement légal le
bailleur social a dit ok si elle paye un
surloyer ce qu'elle fait combien je ne
sais pas on n'a pas la somme du chloyer
on n' pas la somme du chloyer je je ne
l'ai pas donc c'est vrai que les
indemnités si on les cumule d'un député
c'est énorme mais moi je pense que dans
quelques années elle retournera à la vie
civile elle a été connue pour sa lutte
quelques Ann il y a plein de gens qui
vont peut-être trouver du travail dans
quelques années oui mais moi je suis pas
choqué parce que si on l'a de là elle va
vivre où et dans quelques annéve ce
qu'elle prend va trouverouver quelqu
foelle sera
plusp il faudrait justement lui dire que
une fois qu'elle sera plus député pourra
peut-êre inégrer mais après si elle
prend 9000 € par
[Musique]
mois je te reconnais pas je te reconnais
justement la connerie son
paroxi pour moi c'est scandaleux la
morale doit primer en politique quelle
que soit la couleur ti quelle que soit
la position que tu as que tu as eu et
que tu auras à l'avenir sinon alors il y
a tout le monde a une bonne excuse moi
je je je excuse-moi mais je je parlais
de moi j'ai j'ai eu un appartement
social à la RIVP pendant 7 ans j'ai été
nommé à Londres la RIVP c'est la régie
imobilière de la ville de
Paris lorsque j'ai eu l'appartement je
rentrais parfaitement dans les clous 7
ans après je rentrais plus dans les
clous et surtout j'ai été nommé à
Londres j'allais avoir un surplu de
salaire j'ai rendu les clés de mon
appartement tu avais combien d'enfants
j'avais deux enfants je les ai toujours
j'ai j'ai j'ai j'ai j'ai appelé la
mairie et j'ai dit je rends mon
appartement parce que ça me choquait
moralement de pouvoir être correspondant
de gagner quelque chose qui est
comparable à ce qu'elle ce qu'elle
touche aujourd'hui et je suis désolé
mais non c'est quand tu as quitté la
RIVP ouais
j'ai ou c'est le nom de la
ré ta situation professionnelle est pas
la même que celle non mais c'est pas la
même situation
professionn y a plein de gens qui disent
moi j'ai 700 € par mois et j'ai pas
droit à comment a plein des familles qui
ont 4 enfants qui se rrouvve dans des
situations comme ça elle elle doit
montrer l'exemple je suis désolé quand
on représente dans quelques secondes je
vais lâcher Ron euh
oui il est Colire elle do elle doit
monter l'exemple mais non mais combien
de femmes combien de femmes ont quatre
enfants en France cherchent un logement
à chlm et non pas les revenus de Madame
combien
question juste etach serait de droite il
serait pour ou contre qu'elle garde son
logement il serait contre pourit on
pourrait discuter voilà
merci de la clarté puisque ça le mérite
de la clarté g puisque tu as dit tout à
l'heure elle est femme de ménage et elle
a quatre enfants ce qui veut dire que
bah oui mais ce qui veut dire que pour
toi sa position sociale d'avant et
d'après a un impact sur le fait de
savoir si elle doit avoir un logement
social Vous savez qui s Rachel k elle a
galéré toute sa vie elle
ex ronne après quoi qu'il
AR ça ça serait bien on lui garantit
qu'elle le rrouvera après ça oui mais
pour l'instant à 9000 boules par mois je
suis désolé mon ch sur les ré pe quand
même comprendre la dame qui a peur pour
l'avenir pour ses enfants
ai si on lui dit on lui garanouver après
moi je pense que ça c'est bien écoutez
làdus parce que alors moi je trouve que
c'est j'ai pas envie d'accbler cette
femme en fait parce que je trouve que
son parcours il est juste incroyable il
est admirable elle est tellement
singulière que je trouve que évidemment
on peut trouver ça un peu choquant et
évidemment on se dirait ouais peut-être
qu'elle aurait dû partir et tout ça mais
à partir du moment où elle a tout bien
fait elle a prévenu son bailleur elle a
elle a donné un surloyer elle a plutôt
été exemplaire elle a quatre enfants
qu'elle a élevé seule dans cette h bien
sûr qu'elle est pas la seule femme de de
France à avoir quatre enfants seuls bien
sûr que toi Jacques tu as été exemplaire
et et tu as quitté ton HM voilà et bravo
et je t'en félicite mais dans son
caselle elle est prêt de s administrer
elle l'habitude elle a toujours elle a
toujours vécu ici quel âge on connaît
pas quel âge ont ses enfants peut-être
que pour elle c'est important de rester
là je trouve que c'est pas un immense
scandale il y a tellement des immenses
Scand elle a accédé à un rang qui fait
que elle sera toujours entourée et elle
aura une famille politique qui l'aidera
quoi qu' arrête la France insom la
France insomist c'est en train
d'exploser en plein vol ça existera
peut-être pas dans 4 ans et dans 4 ans
elle il va falloir qu'elle remette en
jeu son mandat et seréélu he après dans
ce cas-là peux dire aussi Louis Boyard
il a un fort non
ça
anch tu vois après tu dis voilà quoi bon
ils sont bons dans l'immobilier ils sont
bons dans l'immobilier en Revan je suis
pas du tout d'accord avec Gill quand il
dit c'est une femme elle est noire elle
a subi du racisme non pas du tout c'est
pas du tout pas dit qu'elle était noire
si tu as dit elle a subi du racisme
pourquoi elle a subi du racisme parce
qu'elle est
[Rires]
noire donc non cquant je ne veux pas la
victimisation ça ça ne plaît pas
l'essentialisation ça ne plaît pas c'est
tout ce que déteste du côté de tes amis
justement mais dans son cas précisément
dans dans ce cas particulier j'aimerais
bien qu'on voilà c'est au cas par cas
j'aimerait bien qu'on ait le montant du
surloyer par cas pas de marque pas de
par pardon on embrasse également terre
de fenêtre merci ouii moi le montant du
surloyer il m'intéresse pas je prends
juste les fait et je me dis que c'est
quelquun qui va mais c'est pas
3500 3500 quand tu prends 7 8000 € par
mois
[Applaudissements]
quand tu prends quand tu prends 6 7000 €
par mois tu peux pas tu peux pas dire je
vais aller je vais habiter dans un HLM
il faut laisser la place là où il a
raison Cyril c'est qu'il dit il faudrait
lui garantir après de retrouver un HLM
parce qu'elle a dit elle a dit qu' avec
ses quatre enfants elle voulait pas all
changer d'école elle voulait rester dans
le cadre elle voulait rester là où il
habite là je la suis il y a pas de
problème sauf que on sait très bien ce
qui fait ça c'est qu'il y a de des fois
deux 3 ans d'attente de liste d'attente
pour avoir un HLM donc si elle se barre
de son HLM elle est pas sûre d'en
récupérer un et moi je vais plus loin
pourquoi elle elle serait en priorité
pour récupérer un HLM et pourquoi il y a
des familles qui attendent et qui
galèent 2 3 ans à qui on laisse sur le
carreau et qui touche 7 800 balles et
elle elle a 9000 balles elleut pas
partir
heement message que je reçois ma sœur
seu C enfants dans 45 m Carr n'a
toujours pas de logement social et on
lui a coupé les aides voilà qu'elle
laisse sa place à des gens qui sont
vraiment dans le besoin tu combien
d'enfants dorment dans la rue en France
et dans dans une voitureon il y a plus a
que
ça
non je sués
meut
fa s'il plaît'il plît faut qu' quit qu'
le donne à quelqu'un qui en a vraiment
besoin aujourd'hui à l'instantti et
après si elle est vraiment en difficulté
on lui garantit qu'elle retrouvera son
hlm mais là les gars je suis désolé
Jean-Luc Mélenchon a dit qu'est-ce qu'il
a dit
encore mais j'aimerais bien savoir sa
citation parce que c'est toujours
intéressant oui qui voulait parler non
mais donc il faut qu'elle reste pour une
question de morale parce qu'on est
d'accord qu'elle est pas hors la lo elle
est
pas une question de morale part pour une
question de morale tiens nouvelle
polémique des fachot alors à chaque fois
qu'il y a une polémique Mélenchon c'est
des fach ou racistes comme c'est
toujours son truc mélchon c'est des amis
jein voilà à propos de son lement je
souhaite qu'elle y reste alors lui il
souhaite qu'elle y reste donc lui c'est
lui c'est c'est c'est transac il décide
toi tu un truc c'est un fou transac bon
quit à ce que son loyer soit adapté elle
n'est pas élue à vie c'est une bonne
chose que les élus du peuple
n'abandonnent pas la vie des leur bon
non je suis pas d'accord avec Jean-Luc
Mélenchon elle doit quitter son HLM et
revenir après ce que je pense après
c'est peut-être pas moi qui qui qui
est c'est sa défense elle a demandé à
rester à l'endroit où elle a été élue et
donc qu'elle connait bien et o elle a sa
vie où ses enfants à mon avis il y a des
trucs très sympas là-bas elle peut
trouver un truc un peu
plus
ch elle elle peut trouver un truc et
qu'elle l'URA dans le privé C dans priv
trouver dans privé il y a combien de
locataires elle a les garanties elle a
tout
pointer devant un propriétaire avec 8000
balles par mois il va dire bien sûr que
je teou le truc revenir après excuse
elle le dit dans son communiqué press
que elle ne conçoit pas son rôle d'élu
comme une carrière donc ça veut
dire 21
ça
c'est la politique c'est l'exemplarité
exemplaire elle est exemplaire elle dit
tout elle déclare
tout bien on aurait d lui dire dans ce
donc il faut lui envoyer des huissiers
pour lui direcout hers de justice hers
des haricots
haricots la France insoumise qui est un
parti exemplaire aurait dû lui dire on
veut de l'exemplarité donc tu dois
quitter ton
log complètcqucqu a raison 100% les mecs
l'argument de je c'est c'est précaire et
je ne sais pas si je ferai de la
politique dans 10 ans mais les mecs qui
sait sil va rester à son poste dans 10
ans non mais n'importe quoi il y a des
gens qui se font Rener tous les jours un
mec un mec qui vend des voitures ce qui
sait s' va dans l'immobilier en ce
moment il y a tous les jours des gens
qui se font virés parce que ça bouge pas
etvec l'immobilier est dans une
situation catastrophique alors il va
dire non mais je suis dans l'immobilier
moi donc je vais dire peut-être que dans
2 mois je vais perdre mon taf non mais
il faut arrêter en vérité elle a je le
pense elle a justement un poste qui est
beaucoup plus sûr que beaucoup gens
parce que au moins elle sait qu' lui
reste combien d'années là
encore rendez compte 4 ans qui qui non
mais mais dire que vous êtes fous qui
aujourd'hui a un travail et il se dit
c'est sûr que je serai encore là dans 4
ans et que je vais prendre mon SAL que
ce soit un chef d'entreprise ou que ce
soit un salarié personne ne peut te le
dire calculé 4 ans 80000 x 4
80000à 320000 € voilà donc après même si
elle est plus député elle peut même
s'acheter une
maison
consili vérit 3 précarité c'est une
connerie arrêtez 1200 balles la retraite
après 1200 balles la retraite en plus
aprèsprè ou quoi qu'il en soit très fort
sur les retraites lui même si fait un ça
m'intéresse oui mais après on dit aussi
aussi que quand ils achètent un truc ils
habitent dans des pavillons ils sont
loin de leurs administrés ils sont
horors sol ils connaissent pas la
réalité le quotidien de de ce dont il
parle ti il a un ami à moi un ami à moi
Mélenchon égal retraite à 9000 € par
mois sur jamamais avoir travaillé
retraite de parlementaire merci Stéphan
vrai voilà donc alors non mais mais mais
sil donnit pas des leçons on s'en fout à
la limite mais ils sont tout le temps en
train de donner des leçons lui il a
donné 100 millions au resto c'est pas
assez lui il a fait ça c'est pas assez
lui donne pas assez d'argent lui gagne
trop d'Ar il en donne pas et toi tu
prends semaine dernière la semaine
dernière ils ont critiqué Bernard Arna
qui avait donné 10 millions d'euros du
cœur et derrière dit non elle prend 9000
€ par mois mais elle doit garder son son
logement social non mais les mecs eux
c'est non mais eux ils osent tout voilà
c'est c'est voilà
façon donc Rachel K est victime de
Mélenchon et de son
par était partout ailleurs passerit non
ça passerait pas non plus ça passerait
pas non plus ça passerait nul en vrai à
9000 € par mois tu gardes pas un
lchement social c'est tout et quand tu
sais que tu as 4 ans encore à faire je
suis désolé les mecs c'est un c'est
inaudible on peut pas entendre ça je
suis désolé qui peut se dire aujourd'hui
j'auraai mon taf dans 4 ans mais vous
êtes fous quoi personne personne même
vous et vous les premier d'ailleurs non
mais c'est vrai non mais voilà mais
c'est vrai donc arrêtez les gars elle
c'est sûr de toucher 9000 € par mois
pendant 4 ans r c'est pas sûr s'il font
une
dissolution pas s
tu dis prend 360000 4 pas grave
jeog plus j'ai envie de te dire une
décision qu'elle aa d prendre avant
quand elle s'est engagé en politique
quand elle s'est engagé qu'elle fait
campagneourette FEM fait qu'elle pvit
pas prendre
cettecem m
vie
parcoursem se ont enantsourd'i
a à elle d'avoir d'abord le logement
social exactement même elle je pense
qu'elle devrait dire j'ai envie d'aider
quelqu'un je suis désolé moi j'ai la
chance deme faire un coup politique
exactement
voilà voilà l'intelligence voilà
qu'est-ce qu'il a mais un coup politique
c'est la démagogie
m t'arrêes au seul truc parce que lui il
a pas dit que c'est ce qu'il faut faire
c'est ce qui
VI en fait es plus con que ce que je
pensais mais je t'aime beaucoup mais vra
ex'oup VI dire elle devrait
quitter il a dit
voilàelle dev faire un
coupisme voilà mais toi tu prends tout
au premier
degré qu'est-ce qu'elle va faire si vous
dites elle devrait avoir un logement
social garanti après elle n'en aura
jamais
C G il font comment les autres g 360000
comment ils font pour trouver un
logement ils sont sur liste d'attente
ils prennent 900 balles par mois et ils
attendent que la mairie les appelle
je vais dire la vérité moi elle va
prendre 1200 € après déjà je peux dire
elle peut mettre de l'argent de côté
quose elle occupe un appartement que des
gens peut-être plus nécessitent qu'
besoin les chér on peut partir dans un
débat et dire on pense ça et vu les
arguments que j'ai avancé
Ilang ah c'est bravo bravo
bernardle j' en train de ce n'est pas
être une jourouette c'est juste être
intelligent bravo Bernard c'est ça le
débat j'écoute les arguments des uns et
des autres et là ça changé un peu d'avis
oui un tout petit peu parce que quand
même ouais c'est vrai parce que moi jeis
tout ce qu'elle a fait est légal on peut
pas lui reprocher ça mais en revanche
elle occupe une place que d'autres
personnes plus méritantes les mot qui
sonne ouais vous êtes formidable ça
raisonne dans ma tête regez voir ce qu'
pens les téléspectateurs oui voilà merci
au revoir 75 % merci Gill verd tu peux
encore aller acheter de la des yaourts
là dehors et arrêter de nous faire chier
merci on va se retrouver dans un instant
les amours merci d'être là tellement
heureux